winning winning an Oscar especially as a  young mid-20s budding filmmaker was huge  more than anything else it was an  instant recognition of what it was that  we were trying to do and trying to  experiment with and and more than  anything else is a automatic open door  opener if you will here is closed  mondays will vinton and Bob Gardner  I'd like to thank family and friends and  and will thank you very much thanks to  the members of the Academy for the  incredible honor and hello and and thank  you to all her friends back home in  Oregon before that it would be probably  difficult for you know for a young  filmmaker to sort of be taken seriously  getting in to meet with people and talk  about other projects and so on and after  that it was there was like a calling  card that made it significantly easier